3 harley davidson dévalent les petites
routes de campagne
nous ne sommes pas aux états unis mais
en france dans le département de
l'ardèche sur les motos blouson noir
tatouage pas de casque ce sont des
bikers tous les 6 août ils se rendent à
une réunion de commémoration en
l'honneur d'un des leurs décédé il ya
huit ans dans leur langage
ils appellent cela un mémo
il ya tous les élèves
les ingrédients avoir à manger du
rock'n'roll des amis ça va encore
arriver au fil du week-end franck est
l'organisateur de ce memories sur les
t-shirts sur les murs de la maison leur
héros jean françois andré
surnommé l' api fils d'ouvrier il était
devenu un motard célèbre dans toute la
région
il est mort assassiné le 6 août 2003 son
ou ses meurtriers n'ont jamais été
identifiés
ils ont pas son patron fait le deuil
encore pas trop sûr c'est un peu
difficile et les polars ils ne sont plus
qu'une vingtaine à lui rendra encore
hommage ses plus proches amis sa famille
son père marcel moi j'aurais mais c'est
bon tu sais pas je suis trop vieux et
une machine on discute moto on se
rappelle les meilleurs moments avec le
disparu au milieu du jardin une femme
monte un tipi elles se surnomment
l'indienne c'était la confidente de
l'api il a parfois vécu dans ce type i
lorsqu'il avait des problèmes quand il
voulait se couper du monde
ses soutiens on appelle à réviser tout
en planque et la mouton parmi les
invités en bout de table
une jeune femme blonde elle s'appelle
jennyfer la fille de l'api sur son dos
un tatouage papa je t'aime une légende
est morte mais un mythe est né pas
l'oublier il est toujours là toujours
présente parmi nous
un mythe dans le monde des motards
quelques jours avant de mourir la piété
devenu le chef français d'un groupe de
bikers internationale les outlaws les
hors la loi en français son assassinat
va déclencher une vague de meurtres sans
précédent une vendetta
trois hommes soupçonnés de l'avoir tué
vont à leur tour être exécuté
une véritable tuerie en série entre
drôme et ardèche
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
au sud de lyon le rhône c'est par les
plaines de la drôme à l'est et les
collines de l'ardèche à l'ouest dans le
petit village de champagne
nous avons rendez vous avec jennifer
andré 26 ans la fille aînée de la bi
aujourd'hui femme au foyer et mère de
deux enfants jennifer avait 18 ans quand
son père a été assassiné
tout ce qu'elle a conservé de lui dans
ce petit classeur noir qu'elle
feuillette régulièrement
c'est un dossier que j'ai fait quand mon
père a été assassiné avec les articles
des photos que j'ai pu réunir quand ça
va pas oui quand ça va pas quand j'ai
besoin de voir way où ils restent
souvent dans placard et chez qui les à
côtés donc du coup voilà son père ne
quittez jamais sa moto ni ses vêtements
de cuir
la plupart du temps il s'habille en noir
et blanc
d'où son surnom l'api c'est dans cet
univers peu banal celui des bikers que
jennifer a grandi dans les années 80
c'est quoi le grandir
pas mieux pour un enfant c'est dur parce
que ben on est jugé par rapport à lui et
pas par rapport à nous pas beaucoup
d'amis dans l'enfance à cause de bas de
ce à quoi à cause de d'une réputation
non fondées quoi hein c'est quoi une
réputation bain de gangsters un biker
c'est sûr c'est tout le monde pense
qu'un bikers et automatiquement un
cancer
non c'est l'amour de la moto il est né
voilà l'amour de la moto
l'api est né avec cette passion dans le
sens né en 1961 à quinta un petit
village d'ardèche
il a toujours été fasciné par l'univers
des motards américains
une passion qui l'a transmise à sa
famille sur les routes d'ardèche
nous retrouvons sa soeur jocelyne avec
son mari ils sont eux aussi devenus des
inconditionnels de harley davidson
c'était le seul en région c'est lui qui
a créé le mouvement
dans la région en 1975 à 14 ans la piste
offre sa première mobylette il la
bricole lui-même surélève le guidon pour
qu'elle ressemble à un chopper à l'image
des motos américaines un shop comme dit
sa soeur depuis son enfance soyez oui ça
a commencé à l'âge de 14 ans la pudeur
conduire des motos
il a une à monter ces chocs
c'est sa passion c'était son rêve son
rêve la liberté la moto liberté way
créer créer son shop faire quelque chose
de sa vie en fait
dans les années 70 la piscine l'ardèche
au guidon de son chauffeur et rencontre
d'autres jeunes passionnés de moto comme
franck
ils ont vingt ans quand ils se
rencontrent pour l'api frank était comme
un frère un vrai biker dans la rigole et
bien réglée sur cette ancienne
photographie lapied franck de dos il
arbore le nom de leur premier club de
moto cannes est givrée
franck a toujours vécu de petits boulots
mais l'argent est pour lui sans
importance comme l'api son bien le plus
précieux et sa moto une harley davidson
un modèle unique qui l'a pratiquement
bricoler lui même avec elle il est libre
de partir où il veut et quand bon lui
sans une moto que fait
dans l'esprit d'un cheval sauvage quoi
on a la maîtrise on galère avec caen
c'est un choix aller parfaite comme ça
le biker et de tours est rare et si
bakary le relais c'est peut-être parce
qu'il a envie de dire qu'une envie
d'être libre qui retrouve quelque chose
dans le harley une certaine liberté dans
l'histoire de la harley donc là il
collection entre le personnage et la
marque mais un rebelle c'est individuel
de toute façon on peut rouler après
réfractaires rebelles
l'api n'a pas vraiment d'emploi mais à
24 ans il devient faire nous sommes en
1985 et l'api va se créer une activité
professionnelle au creux de la tyne un
petit village de la drôme le long de la
nationale 7 grâce à l'argent d'un
héritage il achète une grande bâtisse
dans laquelle il ouvre un bar le rn 7 et
un magasin de pièces détachées de moto
sur une large fresque murale
il se fait même représenté sur la
devanture dans les mois qui suivent le
bar de l'api commence à attirer les
motards de la région
ils seront plus d'une trentaine à le
fréquenter régulièrement avec eux l'api
créé au milieu des années 80 un vraie
moto club 1 m6 dans le langage des
bikers il le baptise m6 drôme l'api se
proclame président et attire l'attention
des médias en 2000 la chaîne voyage lui
consacre un reportage sur cette archive
l'appui est interviewé au sujet de la
mythique nationale
c'est pour moi ouais du paysage quoi
s'est il ya beaucoup d'histoires le m6
drôme acquiert une grande notoriété dans
le petit monde de la moto sous l'égide
du club l'appui organise des
concentrations de moto les actions de
charité ou encore des concerts rock
autant d'événements qui booste sa
popularité ancien membre du club
aujourd'hui retraité indiana plus de
motos mais il se souvient avec émotion
de cette époque
cetoula là on est au creux de la tine et
vous vous êtes et moi je suis là quand
ils rencontrent l'api indian tombe
littéralement sous le charme de ce biker
charismatique qu'il décrit comme un chef
un véritable leader c'est ce que j'ai
moi le trouver de mieux en un personnage
en charisme un individu et en
l'honnêteté
il était ce qu'il était mais par contre
il était une voiture on n'a pas fait
beaucoup des comme ça c'était quelqu'un
qui réunissait il ya des gens qui
donnent envie d'avancer dans la vie est
la pire en faisait partie
mais au sein du m6 drôme l'api
n'acceptent pas tous les motards pour
être membre il faut être un homme
possédé une harley chaque membre doit se
jurer secours et fidélité un engagement
qui prime sur leur vraie famille le très
bon
on a intégré au club intéressant la
vache - c'est le club
ouais c'est hyper partir en vacances
parce qu'il ait club s'il y avait un
truc qui se passe avec le club et à côté
un repas de famille déclare à ceux qui
le méritent l'appui offre des patchs
c'est écusson à coudre dans le dos des
blousons des jaquettes en cui des patchs
qui ne sont pas en vente libre grâce à
franck l'indienne a accepté de nous
recevoir chez elle elle voue encore
aujourd'hui un véritable culte à son
ancien ami sur son bras un tatouage au
dessus on peut lire en mémoire à mon
frère assassiné
l'api en dessous trois mots la devise du
m6 drôme respect amitié fraternité dans
son petit appartement un mur entier
consacré à son ancien ami un véritable
mausolée l'indienne a surtout eu le
droit de conserver les patchs de la paix
après sa mort dans le milieu on dit les
couleurs alors ça ce sont ses couleurs
il ya une cedro aidé à ce sont des
photos il y en a des anciennes et en
inde est plus récente
là il ya son dernier bon dos et d'assez
son premier maillot c'était ça les
couleurs ça c'est les couleurs du creux
de la tyne une ces drones en portant les
couleurs
qu'est ce que ça représente des couleurs
mais à quoi tu es arrivé en fin de
compte
tu es dans un club tu fais partie d'un
peuple qui porte les couleurs de ton
club
donc tous ceux qui portent les mêmes
couleurs sont tes frères
des frères des couleurs un lieu de
rendez vous le m6 drôme recrée en
ardèche l'organisation typique des clubs
de motards américains car c'est là bas
aux états unis qu'est née la culture
biker dès sa jeunesse
fasciné par l'amérique l'api il part
aussi souvent qu'il le peut
ils adorent et les états unis l'image la
route 66 tout ça ouais défend et d'un
bon courant qui parti vous savez vous
partez nous même en vacances donc une
profiter de partir en vacances là bas
pour découvrir cette culture biker qui
fascinait l'api nous décollons pour
laconia dans l'état du new hampshire
tous les mois de juin depuis 1923 les
routes environnantes sont prises
d'assaut pendant une semaine par des
centaines de milliers de motards dans ce
paysage montagneux les bikers viennent
ici pour rouler découvrir la région se
rencontrer on appelle ça une
concentration
[Musique]
étape obligée à laconia l'allée centrale
c'est ici que les bikers se gare pour y
faire admirer leur moon 90% sont des
harley davidson toute différente
personnalisés parfois jusqu'à l'outrance
ce gros appareils c'est ma moto porno
c'est tout les fruits que j'ai fait ici
elles sont où
un tour garde déficit en fin de journée
les bikers se retrouve au full throttle
saloon une salle de concert qui annonce
clairement la couleur board arme
interdite à l'intérieur des jeunes
filles sexy payer quelques dollars pour
appâter le client
tout est fait pour exciter un public
presque exclusivement masculin bière et
alcools forts culte à flot
concert de hard rock nous n'avons croisé
presque aucune femme motarde
[Musique]
à lacaune ya les bikers viennent faire
du shopping admirer les mécaniciens au
travail
et surtout acheter de nouveaux patchs à
coudre sur leurs blousons leur jaquette
qu'elle badge préfère les bikers sa
femme préfère les drapeaux les aigles
d'autres les têtes de mort ou les
animaux surtout hard c'est la meilleure
des slogans la plupart agressif contre
les homosexuels les femmes
les mexicains ils sont le reflet d'une
idéologie viril et nationaliste les
bikers aiment leur pays
l'amérique l'un de ces patchs nous mêmes
directement adressés disant non sur la
france qu'on ne suis pas sûr qu'il va
vous plaire à lacaune ya tous les bikers
qui sont membres d'un club affichent
leurs couleurs dans le dos le plus
mythique c'est le club des hells angels
les anges de l'enfer en france est un
club à la réputation sulfureuse leur
logo rouge et blanc représente un crâne
et les halles à konya nous repérons
enfin hells angel nous filmons sa
jaquette ses couleurs la réaction ne
tardera pas
pratiquement impossible d'approcher les
hells angel fondé dans les années 50 en
californie les hell's angel tirent leur
nom d'une escadrille d'aviateur de l' us
air force pendant la seconde guerre
mondiale elle avait acquis une solide
réputation de tueur de nazis mais leur
réputation mondiale les ailes cela
qu'hier le 6 décembre 1969 lors d'un
concert des rolling stones organisé à
altamont en californie ce soir là les
hells angel sont payés par les stones ce
pour assurer leur sécurité
toutacoo panique dans la foule un jeune
spectateur vient de pointer une arme sur
le chanteur mick jagger un hells angels
se ruent sur lui le poignarde le tue
après plusieurs procès la légitime
défense sera prouvée le club des hells
angels a quitté les y gagneront une
réputation mondiale de bad boys de
mauvais garçon selon leur site internet
les hells angel serait cinq à dix mille
présent dans 36 pays dont les etats-unis
la russie l'australie le canada et aussi
la france
régulièrement les hells angel entre en
conflit avec d'autres clubs de motards
comme sur ces images amateurs tournés
dans un casino du nevada aux états unis
en 2010 une gigantesque bagarre éclate
entre des hells et un club rival 3
bikers ont mûri dans l'univers des
bikers sa violence est récurrente
car leur culture est étroitement liée au
monde des vétérans ces anciens soldats
qui ont fait la guerre au vietnam en
irak ou en afghanistan
comme les hells angels de nombreux clubs
à rebours des patchs qui sonne bon lui s
arme
combat bête summer in vétérans ou encore
nam knights les chevaliers du vietnam et
vous ou bien ils étaient plusieurs
autres derrière moi étaient des femmes
on a tous servis en premier league
c'est pourquoi nous portons tous ses
couleurs en souvenir des chevaliers du
rendu à la vie civile
les vétérans peine parfois à se
réinsérer du coup ils se réfugient
souvent dans la culture bikers aux états
unis près de 40 % des acheteurs de
harley sont des vétérans sont revenus de
la guerre ils n'étaient pas respectées
ils se sont sentis abandonnés
nous avons été blessées les gens
critiquer tout ce qui s'était passé
c'est une confrérie
voilà ce que c'est n'importe quel gars
qu'ils portent ne sais pas je ferais
n'importe quoi pour toi je me moque de
qui ils sont c'est la même mentalité que
celle que nous avions dans le service
[Musique]
laconia un club des tonnes les soldiers
fortis leur mission pacifier le monde
des bikers
les membres de ce club ont pour certains
connu la prison avant de rencontrer dieu
ils ont tout arrêté l'alcool la violence
la drogue
tous sauf la moto
il nous invite à une balade ride
au guidon de sa moto moeurs nous raconte
son plaisir de rouler en groupe
[Musique]
j'adore les relais davidson j'ai été
élevé dans cet univers mon père était un
biker ça vient de là vous savez j'aime
le son l'odeur juste la liberté de
rouler sur la route d'être avec mes
frères les gens regardent les pages que
nous avons dans le dos j'adore ça en
ville
ride chacun a une place précise me
refais responsable de la sécurité ferme
la marche à la konya ils sont huit
soldiers fortis qu'il ne prêche pas ils
veulent par leur présence montrer que la
culture biker est compatible avec la non
violence ma mission est d'aller à la
rencontre de la culture biker j'étais à
dicter l'héroïne
voilà qui est fait durant des années
j'ai pu de la drogue j'ai fini en prison
c'est des horreurs doses quand j'ai
rencontré dû la changer ma culture je
sais ce que je veux partager avec les
autres et s'éloigner de ceux là parmi
tous les clubs de motards américains
célèbres dans le monde entier
l'api rêvé d'en intégrer un le plus
radical celui des hells angels
c'est un rêve quoi c'est vraiment le
rêve c'était faire partie de ce club de
cette famille l'a dans le sang neuf
à l'époque la france compte deux clubs
de hell's angels
l'un à paris l'autre à orléans pour s'en
rapprocher l'api doit obtenir pour le m6
drôme une affiliation
cela signifie que m6 drôme et hell's
angels devront s'assurer fraternité et
protection à la fin des années 80 le m6
drôme devient ce qu'on appelle dans le
jargon des motards un club support des
hells angels en était support support
hells angels c'est ça passait très bien
l'époque à l'instar des grands clubs le
m6 drôme revendique un territoire sur
lequel il règne en maître
le voici cartographier par l'api au
début des années 90 ce territoire
s'étend du sud de lyon jusqu'au nord de
marseille
soit pratiquement tout le couloir
rhodanien sur cette aire géographique
l'appui entend imposer ses propres lois
parfois même en se substituant à la
justice officielle
il y avait une petite dame qui tenait
une presse au creux de la chine
la mamie et la peau d'âme c'est souvent
cambriolé jusqu'au jour où la pied il a
dit non ça fait pas mal mais on va
s'occuper de ça et à la plus jamais été
cambriolé ils étaient libres 2 on va
dire du gouvernement au sein du m6 drôme
l'api est un des seuls à avoir une
activité professionnelle car la grande
majorité des bikers du creux de latine
ne travaille pas et passe la plupart de
leurs journées au local
certains sont même financièrement
dépendant de la bi pour aider ses frères
dans le besoin et arrondir ses fins de
mois en chef de bande
l'api organise des trafics sur son
territoire il s'agit généralement de
voler des marchandises transportées dans
les camions qui s'arrête le long de la
nationale 7
l'api sera souvent inquiété par la
justice mais jamais condamné
y'a rien il ya des tombées de camions et
des choses comme ça mais bon il faut
faire un peu d'argent
si on n'a pas d'argent on bouge pas on
est mort vous êtes un camion qui arrose
quoi pendant que les chauffeurs et d'or
où où les chauffeurs il en coût et puis
voilà il ya les chariots et
d'électroménager ça peut être des
vêtements ça devait être n'importe quoi
quoi qui se vendent dans la région après
ces trafics se prépare dans le secret du
local du m6 drones ce lieu est le
véritable centre du club
jennifer accepte de nous ouvrir les
portes du local
aujourd'hui à l'abandon il ne reste
presque rien de l'ambiance qui régnait
autrefois alors là il y avait la porte
blindée une qualité toujours regarder la
caméra à l'extérieur mais attendent
blindés toujours la bagasse ya des tirs
ici non mais dans d autres lieux du coup
il préférait un point de sécurité de
médecins elle avait le ballon du coup
toujours mon père derrière les isérois
ici bas c'était un bar privé déjà donc
qui recevait les amis le club était là
au concert
petite soirée les réunions qu'il fallait
faire en 1992 en marge du m6 drôme
l'api rencontre un certain michel di
bacco à l'époque di bacco sort juste de
prison après une condamnation pour
proxénétisme
il s'est installé à arras sur rhône à
une dizaine de kilomètres du creux de
latine et prend en gérance ce bar
amateurs de motos lee bako sympathise
très vite avec la fille gros caractères
les deux hommes deviennent en très peu
de temps les meilleurs amis du monde
avec lui
la pub a monté une affaire de placements
de machines à sous dans les cafés il n'a
présenté comme un grand ami avec ses
deux enfants dont joue et qu'on est
parti rose qui on a fait des attentes du
bonbon neige
on se voyait pratiquement une fois tous
et toutes les deux semaines si c'était
pas tous les week-ends c'était ouais
c'est bien un animal
une amitié qui durera près de 10 ans
mais en 1999 pour des raisons
mystérieuses
les deux hommes se fâche deviennent
ennemis sans donner d'explication à leur
entourage
un autre ami de l'api croit savoir ce
qui s'est passé son surnom le vampire
selon lui michel di bacco surnommé gros
michel se serait livré à partir de cette
époque un trafic de drogue dans la
région
un trafic que l'api n'aurait pas toléré
sur son territoire qu'est ce qu'il y
avait un très gros mais je pense que
c'est une sorte de cam ne sortent comme
quoi de la drogue de la cram c'est pas
le chichon mais carrément de l'ivac on
faisait de la vente que l'api vous les
bords donc les choses qui sont pas
compatibles donc l'api n'acceptait pas
si la pi se méfie du deal de drogue
c'est que le m6 drôme et ses trafics
attire de plus en plus l'attention des
gendarmes locaux l'appui en a assez il
souhaite sortir de l'illégalité à ses
proches
il parle même de se ranger d'arrêter ces
petits trafics
le père voulait-il continue non il va
avait parlé à d'autres gens qu qu'il
aurait souhaité arrêter tout arrêter
ceux qui n'en pouvaient plus court il y
en avait marre mais pas la moto quoi
mais il voulait arrêter tout ce qui
était à côté way et je pense que
beaucoup qui ont eu peur parce que sans
mon père est le plus rien quoi donc plus
le même train de vie à rien faire à être
assis en terrasse avec un verre à la
main
cool cours la vie coule pour sortir des
activités illégales
l'api monde de nouveaux projets avec son
ami le vampire il veut créer dans la
région un grand centre européen pour les
bikers avec une salle de concert ancien
entrepreneur de spectacles le vampire
possède justement une bâtisse à saint
vallier comme ça à droite photo devant
le panthéon le portail les justes en
cure ensemble il rebaptise l'endroit
reda
je fais un petit robert et le vampire
est nostalgique de cette époque
[Musique]
avant sa mort l'api n'aura organisé ici
qu'un seul concert
[Musique]
alors qu'est ce que je peux vous montrer
pour l'api peut voir ce que la pile a vu
ça et je fais le concert c'est comme ça
on a fait un concert et si on battait
les armes et il y avait de la clientèle
tee shirt et ou non on a fait quand même
600 ont d'entrée un peu sombre pour
rentrer définitivement avec l'illégalité
l'api espère faire grandir le red house
sans faire à terme une véritable source
de revenus commencent à changer de file
il a compris il finit tout à fait chez
nous ils cherchent est pour nous
chercher des trucs et du camion achète
une fois deux fois trop froid aux
enchères ou n'importe où tu vas voir les
bonnes affaires dans le milieu des
motards
l'api et son m6 drôme sont devenus
célèbres en 1997 il va retourner voir
les hells angels à orléans pour leur
demander que le m6 drôme deviennent
maintenant un club elle sa part entière
mais l'api va être rejetée les hells
d'orléans ne veulent pas intégrer
l'ensemble du hem cidre ont contrarié la
pire aurait été jusqu'à se bagarrer avec
les hells mais un règlement de comptes
qui se fait là-bas on sait pas ce qui
s'est réellement réellement passé parce
que on sait que ça c'est taper dessus
mais ça s'est arrêté là pour pas aller
plus loin
il leur a pas eu un bon porte
comportement les avis des hells angels
est ce qui a été fatal quoi
l'api va alors tenter de s'affilier aux
outlaws un club ennemi des hells angels
reconnaissable alors jacques est orné
d'une tête de mort sur des pistes ont
croisé ils ne sont pas présents à
l'époque en france
l'api rêve de les y implanter après une
certaine déception
les autos près c'est quand même nouvelle
route nouvelle aventure 100% preniez ce
qu'on a été au début des années 2000
francs clapiers les autres vont
sillonner l'allemagne la belgique ou
l'angleterre
ils veulent devenir les représentants
des outlaws en france
mondialement c'est ce que les ou taux
attendez il en rêvait depuis des années
qui est un chapitre en france où l'eau
l'api adopte sur son foulard les
couleurs noire et blanche les couleurs
des outlaws dont le monde des motards
ils deviennent officiellement et demi d
autres clubs pour assurer sa sécurité
indian décide de porter en permanence
une arme sur lui naturellement aux
colons et des harnais at on attend on
pour des couleurs dans le doubs on est
le seul club en france à avoir les
couleurs ou tôt à se dire que demain on
va se faire tirer dessus et on n'a pas
le droit de se défendre mais toi à ma
place tu fais quoi tout
au fil des mois la pression monte chez
les futurs outlaws car leur
intronisation approche le 26 juillet
2003 l'api indian franck et trois autres
membres du m6 drôme sont convoqués par
les responsables européens des outlaws
près de manchester en angleterre c'était
d'aller les chercher et couleurs et des
ramener en france
au retour dans la drôme les outlaws
nouveau pose fièrement dans leur local
du creux de latine
c'est la dernière photographie de l'api
bons jours plus tard il est assassiné
aujourd'hui un club outlaw subsistent en
france au havre sur internet
nous apprenons qu'il organise une
journée de commémoration en mémoire de
lacq le premier outlaw français le
meurtre de l'api peut-il être liée à son
appartenance au club nous décidons de
leur poser la question nous les avons
prévenus de notre arrivée avec méfiance
les outlaws ont accepté de nous laisser
filmer l'entrée du local
la seule personne autorisée à nous
parler l'actuel président du club
genre on peut parler à christian
merci
[Musique]
bonjour
vous êtes responsable oui c'est ce qu'on
dit président c'est ça ouais et vous
étiez où les gens lisent pour canal plus
on travaille plus pour l'api l'api était
le responsable
à une époque des outlaw france et donc
si l'anc est évidemment sur
circonstances sa mort est donc mis là
était out l'eau et vous voulez savoir un
petit peu ce que vous pensiez de ce à
quoi c'est tout ce que tu veux savoir
ouais et puis évidemment essayer de
faire une présentation peut-être un
petit peu qu'ils sont les out au
pourquoi on est auto on va te répondre
tombé très content ça et puis y'a pas de
commentaire après des négociations hors
caméra en mémoire de l'api le président
des outlaws du havre nous autorise à
filmé de loin leur ride leur balade dans
les rues du à une autorisation
exceptionnelle car selon les règles
mondiales du club
ils n'apparaissent jamais dans les
médias les outlaws sont présents dans 24
pays
il n'existe aucun recensement officiel
de leur nombre selon les différentes
polices ils seraient entre cinq et dix
mille membres dans le monde
dont une centaine en france
nous arrivons à une station service
certains rejettent maintenant notre
présence le président nous demande de
couper la caméra impossible d'en savoir
plus pour comprendre qui a tué l'api
retour le 6 août 2003 jour de son
assassinat
ce soir là entouré d'une dizaine de
personnes il boit un verre dans son bar
du creux de latine
il est 22h30 la nuit est tombée l'api
décide de rentrer chez lui et enfourche
sa moto
il tarde seul pourtant selon les règles
du club il devrait être escorté par un
de ses frères bikers l'indienne étaient
présentes au bar ce soir là le dernier
ça vous suivez il voulait pas rentrer
tout seul à la ferme
excusez moi et il avait demandé à ce
qu'on l'accompagné personne n'était
disponible et je lui ai dit la pie xi
tueuse sans ma voiture parce qu'elle
était bloquée et je lui dis sans ma
voiture si tu veux je te suis il m'a dit
non c'est pas toi l'faire magnette et je
n'ai plus jamais revu
l'api roule seul dans la nuit il a
précisément 1 km 700 à parcourir c'est
ici derrière cette enceinte que nous
avons filmé deux jours que se trouve sa
maison
la ferme comme il l'appelait un endroit
isolé
le soir du meurtre la ferme est vide
sa femme et ses enfants sont en vacances
à plus de 300 kilomètres de là l'api
quitte la chaussée pour s'engager sur le
chemin de terre il n'a plus que 50
mètres à parcourir avant de rentrer chez
sa lourde moto ne lui permet pas de
rouler vite 20 km heure maximum selon l'
enquête
jennyfer a accepté de revenir là où son
père a été assassiné et de nous
expliquer les événements tels que la
gendarmerie des à reconstituer
si on suit la théorie de des gendarmes
il y avait 1
une personne qui attendait dans l'angle
du mur qui passe à sa hauteur pour
pouvoir lui tirer dans le flanc
d'après lé enquête l'assassin de la pile
attendait cacher derrière ce mur et 9
balles vont être tiré en sa direction
une seule l'atteindra au flanc gauche
l'api est gravement touché
pourtant il accélère pour échapper à son
assassin il dépasse sa maison puis donne
un coup de guidon vers la gauche
s'enfonce dans le champ qui jouxte de la
ferme
c'est là qu'on a retrouvé donc la veine
démarcation il était à deux mètres du
chemin à peu près ici là ouais c'est
exactement ras le tueur méticuleux
remonte alors le chemin pour s'assurer
que l'api est bien mort et lui loge une
dernière balle en plein visage le corps
caché par la hauteur des épis de maïs en
cette saison d'été ne sera retrouvé que
deux jours plus tard par sa compagne
donc la moto et était couche était sur
le côté et lui étaient devant donc le
guidon comme ça et lui comme ça sur coup
chez la tête en avant son guidon
jennyfer nous guide ensuite jusqu'à
quintana petit village d'ardèche
c'est ici que son père a été enterré
devant l'église le jour de la cérémonie
funèbre
plus de deux mille motards sont présents
certains viennent même d'italie
d'allemagne ou de grande-bretagne
c'est normal ça donne des frissons j'en
ai même encore c'est savoir qu'il était
aussi connu que ça
à l'office le cercueil de l'api est
porté par des outlaws de quatre
nationalités différentes
il s'agirait d'un rite réservé aux chefs
au président nous demandons ensuite à
jennyfer de nous accompagner au
cimetière et nous y conduit mais ne
souhaite pas être filmés devant la tombe
de son père c'est là la grosse là bas
qu'on voit là qu est juste un nom au
nord là bas juste aux boules il est mort
va outre l'eau oui et comme disait mon
père oncle aux forêts avoir fait rêver à
autre chose hors la loi a jamais quoi
son assassinat peut-il être lié à ce
club de motards c'est la première piste
suivie par la justice à valence dès le
début de l'instruction le procureur note
dans son rapport
il pourrait s'agir d'un règlement de
comptes entre bandes rivales de bikers
les outlaws est en rivaux des hells
angel mail enquête judiciaire se heurte
à un véritable mur de silence
on est dans un monde que peut-être
niveau ni moi ne connaissant vraiment on
est dans un monde
motards on est dans un monde qui a
qui n'est pas forcément légal le
règlement de comptes entre clubs et une
hypothèse possible sur laquelle les
enquêteurs ont longuement travaillé sans
succès pour les amis de l'api elle est
peu crédible selon eux un règlement de
comptes révisés tous les membres du club
et pas seulement la bi est ce que c'est
un thème qui a fait ça je pense pas en
moi personnellement c'est beau possible
il nous aurait tous plombés toute façon
je fais pas d'illusions il serait venu
ils nous auraient canaries donc pour moi
ça peut pas être ça je ne suis pas sûr
de surcroît que l'api et cette envergure
internationale qui fasse qu'il puisse
être
une cible de quelconques club de moto
c'est un point de vue c'est pas une
vérité mais alors qu'ils auraient eu
intérêt à tuer l'api la justice va
rapidement suivre une deuxième piste
celle d'un assassinat commis par des
proches
l'indienne nous apprend que lorsque le
corps est rendu à la famille
il manque parmi les effets personnels de
l'api le plus important un carré noir
incarnées de compte dont il ne se
séparait jamais qui notait tout
absolument tout mais bon
avec les da à ce qu'on lui devait les
chances étaient enfin valeur puisqu'il
est dans ce cas des grosses sommes de
beaucoup de personnes l'api a prêté de
l'argent il a dépanné beaucoup de monde
[Musique]
donc
sa disparition a arrangé aussi quelque
part des gens qui pouvaient pas
rembourser et l'indienne nous livre un
autre détail troublant qui peut laisser
penser à l'implication d'un de ses
frères comme l'a pu les appeler sa
jaquette été doublés en kevlar un vrai
gilet pare balles la pile à porter tous
les jours sauf le soir du meurtre
il avait deux jaquettes j'avais fait une
normale et une avec du tiff l'art à
l'intérieur et sur celle là
1 ils n'apportaient pas déjà le jour de
son décès parce qu'il devait me l'a
donné poursuit m couleurs et il a pas eu
tant en fait si l'on reporté ce gilet là
je pense pas qu'à l'heure actuelle il
serait nominé est ce que quelqu'un que
courant du fusil portait pas son gilles
en q1 oui tous ses frères qui étaient là
sur le sur ces deux éléments
la justice va placer en garde à vue dix
sept personnes dont la plupart étaient
présentes au bar le soir du meurtre
un véritable coup de filet chacun est
accusé d'avoir tué la pi seuls leurs
mobiles changent jalousie à l'égard du
chef dette même vol tout y passe
j'ai une juge de valence qui n'en
accusés de meurtre avec préméditation ou
en bande organisée donc ses vingt ans de
prison d'un an présence elles ont raison
soit les gens que j'avais tué larry et
pourquoi pas parce que je voulais
prendre sa place
j'avais quelques mois ok j'ai été accusé
d'homicide volontaire avec préméditation
on nous accuser sa compagne et moi de
d'avoir tué l'appui pour ses biens
l'opération des gendarmes est un échec
tous ont un alibi malgré l'absence du
carnet de compte
malgré la substitution de jaquettes
cette seconde piste suivie par les
enquêteurs s'effondre ils vont alors
suivre une troisième piste celle de
michel di bacco l'ancien ami de l'api
qui aurait vendu de la drogue sur le
territoire du m6 drôme nous avons
rendez-vous quelque part en france avec
un ancien proche de dih bakou nous
l'appellerons aldo aldo a quittés il ya
longtemps la région de la drum avec
michel di bacco il a été soupçonné du
meurtre de l'api et a accepté de
témoigner à visage caché
simple et de cahiers du cours ben non on
va pas que ce soit des crises c'est un
peu le tir et turbulent du congo il se
faisait une petite guéguerre de c'était
pour toi en quoi c'était pas méchant à
taper sur comme ce soit aussi c'est vrai
qu'ils disputaient un peu des fois où
des choses comme ça avec l'alcool
qu'autre chose il n'y a jamais eu
vraiment de deguines en fait on trop il
est est ce qu'on va du corps diamant la
haine entre la pied michel di bacco et
légendaire à l'époque et le 30 juillet
2003 huit jours avant l'assassinât de
l'api la tension va monter d'un cran
entre les deux hommes
un restaurant de motards au creux de la
tyne en plein sur le territoire de lac
michel di bacco décide d'y dîner en
compagnie d'aldo l'api débarque
il est armé et manifestement furieux
mais plutôt que de s'en prendre à michel
di bacco l'api va menacer halde puis
s'en est pris au mot sans offrir mon
c'est là il va arriver avec un pistolet
déjà même heure la chasse et là j'ai pas
trop compris parce qu'avec l'alcool il y
avait tout ce qu'on voulait compter ce
qui fut dit la tipp vous en venant c'est
pas qu'ils m'envoient mans c'est qu'il
essaie de toucher les cheveux courts ou
c1 comprend s'il ya quelque chose de la
temps entre eux mais on peut pas
percevoir licence et ce qu'ils avaient
de la tank ou et puis la pluie là il
n'en a vendu que michel je suis
catégorique bien nous tous chez colas en
cours sympa de jouer justement ça
s'arrange et ça s'est terminé là
tiennent à la vienne qu auront entendu à
contenir des contres thierry l'api a
tiré en l'air
il ya heureusement aucun blessé ce soir
là placé en garde à vue
iba co confirme aux gendarmes la dispute
qui l'a opposé à l'appui le coup de feu
en l'air ainsi que son désaccord avec
l'appui il devient le suspect numéro un
mais j'imagine que ça m'échappe du
naturel parce que moi je l'accompagné
que je conduisais hoya 7 fantasme du
gendarme que j'avais mais aldo et michel
di bacco ont des alibis le soir du crime
ils étaient tous les deux à saint
vallier dans un bar à plusieurs
kilomètres de là en compagnie d'un
troisième témoin le beau père de michel
di bacco moment où ça se pose moins le
sud en ce moment je suis dans ce bon
plan mais j'ai aimé chez nous ont joints
exactement autour de lui trois nuits non
moi je ne sais pas que leurs élus locaux
il sent qu'il est un alibi en tout cas
il a été retenu puisque puisque monsieur
di bacco n'a pas été mis en examen des
alibis pour le soir du crime
pourtant les gendarmes vont continuer
sur cette piste car un renseignement
anonyme leur parvient comme le souligne
le réquisitoire du procureur
le commanditaire serait dit bako qui a
été braquée et menacé quelques temps
auparavant par l'api le tireur serait un
associé de di bacco ayant les cheveux
gris coiffés en queue de cheval
en enquêtant sur l'entourage de di bacco
la justice va découvrir l'homme aux
cheveux gris gerald de cruz et ancien
biker et collectionneur d'armes
cet homme aujourd'hui décédé était un
ami un voisin de michel di bacco c'est
lui a même acheté un garage à arras sur
rhône
sur place nous retrouvons sa soeur elle
ne croit pas du tout à la culpabilité de
son frère michel di bacco vivait ici
avec son épouse et ses deux enfants
il était copain michel
venez là
voilà il passer au garage il entreposer
ses voitures
voilà il aller boire un coup ensemble en
face c'est voilà ça dépend au départ il
ya déjà pas mal de temps ça leur
arrivait de faire un peu la fête
ensemble et tout ça et puis dans a pris
petit à petit mon frère un petit peu
s'est lassé des frasques un peu de
michel et amis un peu les distances avec
lui pour ses proches
gerald khoo êtes un homme pacifique père
célibataire bon vivant pas le profil
d'un duel mais les gendarmes le
soupçonne ils vont le placer en garde à
vue cherchez une norme pour voir parce
que mon frère était collectionneur
d'armes et il avait pas mal d'armes chez
lui sont venus perquisitionner pour voir
s'ils avaient pas une arme qui
correspondait aux moeurs ils ont rien
trouvé d'ailleurs et et de là
voilà après là était un il a été relaxé
[Musique]
la justice piétine mais dans la région
la rumeur enfle une rumeur nourri par
michel di bacco lui même dans son bar
quand il a trop bu
il se vante régulièrement d'être à
l'origine du meurtre de l'api et parer à
tout le monde à s'envoler à tout le
monde le soir calabre italie et le dire
à tout le monde que c'est lui qui la
fumée la seule chose qu'on peut lourds
pourraient éventuellement lui reprocher
michel sinoir on va tirer gloriole de ça
qui est pour quelque chose dans
l'histoire mais ce semblant de rien quoi
voilà si ce temps d'y attirer la
nouvelle elle a demandé des défaites
comme même si c'était pour lui ces
personnes il est paraît possible qu'ils
se soit vanté de choses qui le précède
je vais pas vous mentir sur ce point
sépare être possible du tout alors au
fil des mois le poison de la rumeur se
répand michel di bacco aurait tué la pi
avec aldo et gérald crouzet cinq ans
plus tard nous sommes en 2008
l'ardèche va être le théâtre de meurtres
en série en moins d'un an michel di
bacco gerald de couze et un troisième
homme marc népote si un ami proche de di
bacco vont à leur tour être assassiné
trois morts dont deux soupçonné un temps
d'avoir tué la pi quelqu'un at il voulu
faire justice venger la mort du biker
tout commence le 13 avril 2008 14 heures
sur la route de haras sureau la soeur de
gérald de cruz et nous conduit jusqu'à
l'endroit où la voiture de son frère a
été retrouvé cet après midi là à la
sortie d'un virage
un soi-disant accident de voiture
si l'on a retrouvé la voiture dont
contrebas de la route
les secours conclu à une crise cardiaque
et bien au départ on modique donc mon
frère harry veulent de là bas et qu'il
aurait fait son arrêt cardiaque
il aurait tiré tout droit et venir
s'écraser contre cette fière carole
rosier a des doutes et demande à voir le
véhicule de son frère elle va y faire
une étonnante découverte des traces de
sang dans l'habitacle aucune trace côté
conducteur
par contre une mare inonde le côté
passager le sang a même gicler jusque
sur le toit et les sièges arrière on
voyait un des éclaboussures de sang qui
partait du côté conducteur jusque
derrière ça faisait une projection de
sang qui collait pas du tout avec avec
ce qu'on avait dit
sans oser penser à un assassinat carole
ne s'explique pas ces étranges
projections de sang mais elle garde ses
doutes pour elle et trois mois plus tard
nouveau coup de théâtre le 29 juillet
2008 alors que michel be back au bois un
verre à la terrasse de son bar deux
hommes en moto ce gars le passager
arrière braquent un pistolet mitrailleur
de calibre 9 mm et yves di bacco est
frappé de 13 balles
il meurt sur le coup en trois mois deux
des principaux suspects de l'assassinât
de l'api sont morts intrigués la justice
ordonne alors l'exhumation du corps de
gérald cruz et aux légumes pour faire
une autopsie pour voir si mon frère a
bien fait une crise cardiaque et tout sa
suite à l'assassinât de michel di bacco
il essaye de voir si les affaires ne
sont pas liées et que suit des cours il
découvre que mon frère est mort d'une
balle dans la tête
[Musique]
il a été tiré de l'extérieur de la
voiture il a été tiré de l'extérieur de
la voiture de la gauche vers la droite
sas a été déterminé par les légistes et
dans l'entourage de di bacco les
meurtres ne s'arrête pas là le 20
février 2009
un troisième homme marc népote six
mécaniciens et bras droit de michel di
bacco disparaît mystérieusement
les enquêteurs pensent alors qu'un tueur
en série est en train de venger la mort
de l'api ils vont s'intéresser à un
homme honoré en qui il n'existe de lui
que ses deux photographies issues de
l'identité judiciaire
honoré ans qui a passé la majeure partie
de sa vie en prison pour braquages
agressions et meurtres
les enquêteurs le soupçonnent pour deux
raisons on aux raisons qui est sorti de
prison 15 jours seulement avant que ne
commence la série d'assassinats il était
surtout l'un des meilleurs amis de la
pcc dont un ami très proche de mon père
qui a toujours été là dans les moins
bons moments difficiles on peut dire
qu'il l'a remplacé lui pour les choses
importantes
il était là pour son avocat ono raison
qui est d'abord un voyou à l'ancienne un
véritable homme d'honneur à cette
constante chez un qui sait
cette fidélité et donc il a ça en lui en
plus c'est cette règle qui lui convenait
parfaitement dans ce milieu dans le
milieu et
donc on est d'abord fidèle aux amis et
l'api c'était son ami
début 2009 ono raison qui est placé sous
surveillance discrète
les gendarmes mettent des micros dans sa
voiture il va se livrer à des
confidences au volant il va évoquer la
disparition de marc népote il s'autorise
la voiture et là évidemment ceux pensant
tout à fait à l'abri des oreilles
indiscrètes dans la voiture no raisons
qui parle à quelqu'un qui n'est pas
identifiée et parle très clairement du
lieu où l'on va retrouver grâce
d'ailleurs à ses déclarations où l'on va
retrouver le corps de marque n'est
possible ono raisons qui parle de la
roche perd et andres en patois local
le nom de ce grand rocher signifie la
roche où a péri andré prendrait le nom
de famille de l'api
les enquêteurs vont alors fouillé les
alentours et trouve enterrer le corps du
disparu
le visage défiguré par un objet
contondant honoré ans quitte ensuite
arrêté à quart serré et mise en examen
pour les trois cris en fait nos raisons
qui j'en suis persuadé
dans son esprit remplir un devoir sacré
d'amitié en vengeant jean françois andré
et en pensant en tuant notamment gerald
de crozet michel di bacco et marque
n'est possible avoir en ligne de mire
les auteurs de l'assassinât de jean
françois andré une vengeance une
vendetta au coeur de la drôme et de
l'ardèche
l'avocat deux ans qui lui affirme que
son client est innocent
personne n'a jamais su qui avait tué
l'api et si c'était vraiment dit bako
donc gens qui ne le sait pas pas plus
qu'un autre
donc c'est ce qu'il dit moi voilà jeu
j'en savais rien je n'allais pas tirer
sur quelqu'un
le procès de nos raisons qui se tiendra
l'année prochaine à la cour d'assises de
valence mise en examen pour trois
assassinats
il risque la réclusion criminelle à
perpétuité
quant à savoir qui a tué l'api la
justice aveux de son impuissance
s'apprête à prononcer un non lieu
il n'y aura jamais de coupables sauf si
un élément nouveau permettait de
relancer l' enquête alors le mystère de
la mort de l'api perdurera la mort d'un
rebelle d'un vrai biker exécuté au
guidon du bic drôme machine sa mythique
harley davidson
[Musique]
non
quoi
à
[Musique]
on
à